hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be all about the post-credits scenes
from Captain America Civil War so
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the movie yet so there were two
post-credit scenes one was like a
mid-credits scene addressing what
happens to Winter Soldier what's going
on with Black Panther the other is like
an actual post-credit scene that happens
after the very final credits which is
spider-man both very exciting but I
think the spider-man one is a little bit
more fun just because I'm really excited
to see where Iron Man and spider-man go
in this new franchise Iron Man is just
gonna be a part of it but an important
part most of you know they dramatically
changed the plot of Marvel Civil War so
really there are only a few things that
comic-book civil war has in common with
movie Civil War but Tony Stark's
top-to-bottom redesign of Spider Man
suit is just a nice nod to the iron
spider suit of Civil War
hey every once in a while Spiderman gets
a new suit Civil War just happened to be
a really cool version of the Iron Man
suit so even though the Russos did say
he would probably get a new version of
the suit for infinity war I'm expecting
him to wear the same Spider Man costume
through most of his new trilogy there
will be three new Spider Man films at
least that's what they planned that
might change down the road there might
be more than that who knows but there
are a couple really important things
that happen in that conversation with
Aunt May you know as he's sitting in bed
kind of nursing his wounds playing with
the new toys the Iron Man gave him Aunt
May starts asking him about what
happened and he says I met a friend from
Brooklyn he's talking about Captain
America so he still thinks of Captain
America as a friend even though he was
on the other side of the fight you
should have seen the big guy talking
about giant man he was real big so he
really still is this little kid
character and I think that's why a lot
of people love him is because he's a kid
playing a kid with all this weight
thrust upon his shoulders so he's gonna
be this really pure motormouth character
as opposed to set you know in the
converse a lot of people were comparing
it to the Tobey Maguire spider-man how
he might not have been the best
character for that because he's such an
introvert he's so quiet and during the
film when spider-man is fighting Winter
Soldier and Falcon it's a perfect
example of what his characters like he
won't shut up you know there's not
usually this much talking in a fight oh
sorry sorry about that
that's pure spider-man from the comics
so that's gonna be this version of
spider-man in the new trilogy so when we
get that Home Coming movie next summer
he's gonna feel just like he felt in
this movie even though he'll be
interacting with a bunch of different
characters it'll probably be localized
to New York City if you've been
in the comic books they did make the new
version of Peter Parker like post Secret
Wars Peter Parker more of an
international character there's a lot
more Tony Stark type things going on in
his background but that's like a
completely different version of the
character movie spider-man will just be
consistent across all the Sony films all
the Marvel films it's a shared universe
it's like the shared Marvel Cinematic
Universe so they will maintain internal
consistency across all those franchises
there were a lot of questions about what
the actual web shooters do so basically
what Tony Stark gave him is a suit
that's I mean I don't think it's
anything special beyond like a really
strong fabric maybe the infinity war
costume will be made out of vibranium
we'll talk about that in a second but
the first time he met Peter Parker he
talked about how he had to wear the
goggles because he had this sensory
overload like his eyes had started to
work a lot more like spiders eyes so he
was just getting too much input for his
brain to handle so that's why his suit
has the irises so when he gets way too
intense he can narrow his field of
vision so he doesn't get too much input
in the middle of a big fight but that
aside he probably helped spider-man
tweak the webbing a little bit as well
as the mechanics of the actual web
shooter so in addition to housing the
fluid that he makes his webs from it
also has a version of the Friday
interface so you know like Iron Man's
heads-up display it's kind of like that
not quite the same thing but it's based
on the same technology it's not like he
has artificial intelligence or anything
like that he doesn't have a version of
Friday but think of the web shooters now
as being like a Swiss Army tool with a
bunch of different functions he has the
spider signal like in the comics he also
has a digital readout so he can access
any kind of information that he might
need like an iPhone on steroids that can
run different apps so like he probably
has diagnostic tools any really any kind
of software that you could possibly
imagine
all the same software that Tony Stark
runs inside his suits but they're
actually still locking down a lot of the
bits for the spider-man movie so I think
once we find out who the main villain is
we can think about how Tony Stark my fin
into that because he's kind of stepping
in and filling the Uncle Ben role being
like the surrogate father and like I
said in my Easter egg or maybe my review
video I think that's gonna help Tony
Stark work through a lot of his grief
over what happened during Civil War
worked through the grief of his parents
never getting to say goodbye to his
father
it sounds like based on what happened
during the movie that he was actually a
pretty big dick that last time
actually talk to his father I wish it
would have gone down that way when he
was looking at the fictitious version of
it so post-civil war Tony Stark is just
like trying to get his together
deal with this new task force that he's
working under and it sounds like he's
looking at Spider Man and Aunt May is
like this bright shining symbol of the
ideal version of himself like the son
that he does not have so I think the
best way that the new Spider Man movies
could use Iron Man
you know without him overpowering the
movie like if you bring him in like you
brought him in in Civil War he could
almost outshine Spider Man and that's
not the goal it's gonna be a Spider Man
film but I think he could be an adviser
for spider-man to go to when he needs
help with a problem if you need some
tech upgrades maybe an assist in a big
fight with a villain late in the movie
but just like spider-man balanced the
tone of civil war just made it this
awesome really hopeful thing I think the
Iron Man could do the same thing for
Spider Man but there's also all the fun
Tony Stark Aunt May scenes just because
Marisa Tomei and Robert Downey jr. have
so much history together so it's just
fun to watch the chemistry that they
have on-screen and there's just so many
ways they could take that but moving on
to the black panther post-credit scene
so here's the big deal with that that's
just giving you a look at Wakanda we're
gonna be all up in it in the black
panther movie but I think the scene
actually works better for people who
don't know anything about the black
panther character or Wakanda because you
hear it's in Africa but you don't really
get the sense that it's this very
wealthy very scientifically advanced
nation despite being near a lot of
third-world countries so it can be a bit
of a double-take like you just you see
all the technology that they have looks
super advanced they kind of addressed it
during the movie where King takaka is
saying we have this history of isolating
ourselves from the world we're not going
to do that anymore so now that black
panther is king of Wakanda he's gonna be
taking a larger role in world affairs in
the fun thing they don't really address
it too much in the movie but Everett
Ross played by Martin Freeman's
character is a big black panther
comic-book character so we think we're
gonna see him show up during the Black
Panther movie so what about the Winter
Soldier what's gonna happen to him and
what's gonna happen to Black Panthers
relationship with Captain America well
he'll probably assist Captain America a
little bit but it sounds like Black
Panthers mostly going to be working with
the government version of The Avengers
the Tony Stark Avengers not Captain
America's Secret Avengers but Kevin
Feige did say that they're committed to
making a Black Widow phase four movie he
didn't say phase four he just said
they're committed to making a black
widow movie and based on the timeline
it just sounds like it would fit better
into phase four if they've already got
so many films during phase three but
anything could happen
I think Winter Soldier would be a good
person to bring back for a black widow
movie because they have so much history
in the comics even if you don't
immediately bring him back in present
day like you don't unfreeze him right
away which they probably would a new
movie there's another whole Winter
Soldier movie in all the backstory we
haven't seen like we've seen a couple
flashbacks him killing Tony Stark's
parents him getting unfrozen for a
couple missions but there's so much
history there ever since he became the
Winter Soldier after World War two he
would get unfrozen on a regular basis to
go on missions then get refrozen so
think about all those Winter Soldier
missions that we haven't seen
do you remember killing them I remember
every one I don't know if they actually
confirmed that Winter Soldier is coming
back for infinity war he might but when
he does come back I think he'll probably
end up getting a vibranium arm now that
we have black panther that doesn't
automatically mean he's just gonna start
passing vibranium around to everyone but
it'd be really awesome to see Iron Man
make a vibranium suit spider-man get a
vibranium version of his suit is what
you would call vibranium weave so it
works a little bit more like vision suit
although vision just kind of manifests
his suit he can change his appearance at
will but when you look at the green suit
here that's kind of the texture that I
think a Spiderman vibranium suit would
look like but let me know in the
comments do you think that by the time
we get to infinity war you'll see
vibranium upgrades for everybody's suits
that would actually be pretty badass and
in related news I know it's still a
little ways off but I'll probably start
doing more guardians of the galaxy
videos that's gonna be the spring movie
next year there should be some more
Doctor Strange stuff coming down the
pipe to they they haven't really dropped
any new teasers or trailers recently but
once we get closer to the summer we'll
probably start seeing a lot more of that
and it's not super related but let me
know in the comments they're actually
getting ready to drop a new Voltron
series on Netflix if that's something
that you guys would want me to make
videos for just let me know it actually
looks pretty cool because it's being
animated by the same people that
animated Legend of Korra giveaway time
congratulations for this week's ticket
giveaway winner amato kareem you gonna
give certificate for to imax tickets be
sure to private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details that's just on the about
page while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for my
Game of Thrones video from last night
and you can click
here for all my Civil War Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you